what happened
Christmas Day 1984 anybody remember oh
the cop that shot huh the cop got shot
in Queens with the Scarface came out
Scarface was a Christmas movie got
released December 25th no no no
1984. go ahead prop it up right now
[Music]
[__] people were running out of
[__] things over here
okay they thought they were gonna go
ahead and hit a jingle bells they heard
10 million [__]
when I landed was February 1st guys the
movie bombed at the box office really at
the airport in Newark when they were
picking me up my [__] gorilla friends
they were like did you see Scarface yet
and I go no
I heard about it I saw the commercials
in Aspen
and they go we're going right now and we
went to Secaucus Harmon Cove
how many movies they got like 18 over
there yeah they had four movie theaters
Scarface it was three in the afternoon
all of them were sold out we couldn't
even sit together like the first time I
saw a Scarface my friend sat somewhere
else the place was packed and that's
what I was walking into
it was a different city it was
everything had changed in this city
right it was the city was on [__]
fire like if you guys are having fun now
you would have killed yourself in 83.
this city was tremendous
come on now 75 85 the stones after they
put miss you out that that [__] album
was New York City so it just picked
[__] New York City up again New York
City was a [__] I still remember
coming over here at night like we would
close the bars in Jersey at three drive
over
get a [__] case of beer and sit on
the street and drink and snort coke on
the hood of your car
nobody would say a word you'd have a
mirror out I'm the hood of the [__]
car yeah and no [__] would say a
word then so that's what I was walking
into that was the General attitude okay
so when was the city broke was it the
70s that New York was like falling apart
this [__] city has been broke for 2
000 years but they still figure out a
way to kill a thousand people a year
right
how the [__] all these people this
shit's been broke since I was a goddamn
kid but it was like 82 83 84 to go out
in the city it was a different city and
then what did I do I got myself a job
bartend at the Sheridan Center on 52nd
and seven from one from
I think I wanted to
at four in the afternoon to one in the
morning for now you're letting a 21 year
old kid
out into Manhattan in 1985 with 200 in
this pocket and a gram of blow and
you're already in Times Square and I'm
already in the heart of New York City
and they're just telling you to go to
Limelight go to this bar ask the [__]
with many Blanco go to this place I mean
the city was on [__] fire you know
they were conscious everywhere like the
way it is now you know just in a smaller
scale you know it was just crazy when
when you're coming up in the city do you
remember like
you know how you look back and we hear
about like the gangsters who did Denzel
play
what was his name uh uh he was Bumpy's
drive though do you remember hearing
about bumpies
no no so these people were protected
Frank Lucas Lucas is Bumpy like do you
remember hearing about these and even
some like the Italian mob guys
neighborhood ever do you see anybody
coming around I heard about bumpy like
when I was running numbers right Harlem
I always heard little stories about him
and [__] I never saw him or anything
like that the gangsters I knew about a
guy named Fat Tony Salerno when I was a
kid oh [__] because he was in Harlem and
that's why I would always be so that one
of your running numbers in all of them
like make sure you don't go into that
neighborhood right you know that's that
Turf over there so I remember [__] like
that but not
no nothing no nothing not nothing too
[__] outrageous people were aware of
them but you weren't interacting with
them yes because you see these movies
that kind of romanticize their role in
New York history but I I you know live
is obviously too young at the time but
I'm like how big were these guys like it
seemed like they ran the entire city
well like Brooklyn guys I bet like a lot
of Brooklyn guys a little maybe 20 years
younger than me they've got a thousand
[__] in fact I live around the
neighborhood was lost Staten Island
people and they tell me a lot of stories
about Sammy the bull and the other guys
yeah because they were getting they were
right there they were right there in
Staten Island at the time yeah you know
so that's real interesting but I never
really saw anybody like that wow and
when you were walking around with cash
and Below did you ever have a gun on you
like for protection
it was I always learned that when you
put a gun on you it's a magnet guys so
before you put that [__] gun on your
[__] thing thinking you're a cool guy
you better think about it's a magnet
you're gonna think about how when you
wear a gun you're gonna start hugging
people and you're gonna feel a gun and
you're gonna go whoa you ever hug
somebody and feel a gun takes your
energy away when you don't expect it you
know if it's like a cop yeah but like
somebody you hug them and also you feel
like a [__] cabinet under their arm
you're like okay it changes the energy
in the room it kind of really does
I carried a gun because I was a stupid
kid not because I knew anything yeah to
do with it and then as I got older I got
into guns and now I don't want them
around me because of that reason
um